so seven possible
future application of neurolink will be
the ability to
save and replay memories or save and
replay mine states
it's a way to do what uh daniel kahneman
for example
talks about as many of us kind of
live life through memories
of previous events so kind of the
memorable
special things that happen to us are
experienced
more deeply and more frequently through
our memories
than directly when we actually
experience them for the first time
and the exciting possibility of
neuralink is
basically improving the resolution
of that memory replay that we generally
do anyway
as people should check out daniel
kahneman's work he
describes it quite eloquently and it's
true many of us
live in our memories it's also from a
certain perspective
nice to be able to modify delete
or alter some of those memories so for
example on a
on a darker side it could be traumatic
events that
you know from a psychological
perspective could be haunting
you can remove or at least alleviate the
impact of those memories
onto your cognition or maybe pull stuff
from the subconscious
you can think of it as a freud's
favorite kind of toolkit
to uh play around and explore with our
own mind to discover our demons
so as opposed to the david goggins
approach that i've taken recently
of doing insane amounts of exercise to
uh
to discover and have a conversation with
my demons could do it in a more
controlled and safe environment
of uh brain computer interfaces as a
quick side note there's interesting
echoes
of uh the memory replay that you've seen
our reinforcement learning systems so
it's kind of interesting to think that
instead of just us being able to replay
our memories
it could be our own little machine
learning systems that can
learn something from our previous
memories by replaying them over and over
to try to give us maybe a strategy of
how to avoid those memories in the past
so it's basically converting our prior
experiences into data
and once it's converted into data that
could be
used for all kinds of applications so
you can think of like a personal machine
learning system that can
replay your memories and try to figure
out try to be a
personal executive assistant to you to
advise you what to learn from those
experiences
with a lot of these applications that
i've already discussed
privacy and security is of paramount
importance i mean like with actually
a lot of our technology but this is very
much at the forefront
of what uh neurolink is working on
currently and
always will be and i think a lot of
companies in general in a tech space
will
sink or swim based on how much they
respect privacy and security
i think in the early days of our
development with social networks and so
on
you could get away easier by being
careless with people's data
i think my long-term perhaps optimistic
but i think
it's a realistic view of the future that
people will demand
much more control over their data
demand much more transparency around
privacy and security
transparency and clarity so of course
that's underlying all the different
features that i'm
discussing and finally to move a little
bit beyond
the ability to save and replay memories
is to save mental states
and that's essentially a path towards
digital immortality
so you can think of being able to save
the contents
or the critical contents of your mind
into
digital form and then being able to
transfer to other systems
to robots or as in for example my
discussion with sarah seeger who
searches for habitable planets outside
our solar system
exoplanets we discussed the idea that
one way perhaps to reach far away
livable planets that might have
extraterrestrial intelligent life on
them
is by sending digital humans there
so being able to save essential or
entire contents of the human mind and to
be able to
reload it once you arrive into uh
any kind of whether it's a biological or
a robotic system
so that's that's the kind of stuff that
ray kurzweil thinks about
it's also a kind of stuff that i think a
lot of people
are excited about is the ability to
store and digitally transfer the
contents
the important the beautiful contents of
the human mind
you